I don't know
right now
all right so that's North Hollywood and
then check out this scene where three
people were arrested yesterday
demonstrations outside the Glendale
School District building that's also in
L.A county and what was going on there
while a district meeting was being held
on lgbtq studies and the superintendent
there recommended the Board of Education
adopt a resolution to designate June as
a lgbtq plus pride month a very big
Armenian population there some people
weren't even parents but they did get
into The Fray there and again a lot of
arrests and emotions erupting in
Glendale California John all right let's
check in now with Dave Rubin host of the
Reuben report to get his take on this
Dave great to see you
God I'm freaking out are you telling me
that a four inch transgender flag was
burned did I just hear that correctly I
actually know that I did because I know
the story it turns out it was a little
flag that was in a potted plant which
was also knocked over and it's like well
what happened to the succulent is anyone
out there protesting for the lives of
succulents no succulent lives matter
succulents yeah succulent lives matter
but it is getting chippy out there I
said yesterday that you can mark this
day down your calendar June 6 2023 as a
day which most people in America realize
this stuff has gone way too far and you
know we point this out this is Los
Angeles right liberal Los Angeles this
is not deep red Florida or anywhere else
where these parents have had enough
yeah look as that woman said in in your
intro there you know there's an
age-appropriate conversation that we can
have uh or we can at least have the
conversation should any of this stuff be
discussed or taught in schools But
ultimately as a parent it's your job to
decide what your child is going to learn
the fact that they are trying to inject
this into elementary schools let's just
remove the the junior high and the High
School portion of it that they would be
talking about sexuality you know second
third fourth graders is so crazy these
kids don't know about it it doesn't
really compute in their brains which are
still developing uh they're
intentionally confusing these kids uh
this is has nothing to do with being
against gay people and as that woman
said there are gay parents at that
school okay nobody was protesting them
two months ago it's when you
intentionally try to bring sexuality and
the rest of this woke nonsense there's
obviously a racial element to it too
usually uh when you bring all of this
then eventually parents push back I
assure you all of those pair it's there
that we're standing there with signs for
religious liberty and leave our kids
alone most of them happen to be Armenian
it's a big Armenian community in
Glendale I used to do a show out of
there a lot of great people none of them
were looking to protest none of them
were looking to fight anybody they want
their kids left alone or say to be
taught the same way any of us would have
been taught say in the rest of American
History how about that yeah good good
point and we heard a parent on National
report earlier and he just says leave
our kids alone keep this ideology out of
our schools and he was his point was
that they're like a 5 out of 10 when it
comes to reading and math in their
school and he says that's the priority
got to make sure kids can read and do
math first before you start injecting
John no no reading and math they're no
longer what they're doing at schools
it's about can you paint a pride flag if
you can do that you can do anything
that's right that's right well I wanted
to ask you a combo question Dave about
illegal immigration here coincidentally
these stories are not going to be on CNN
as you would probably rightly point out
here Florida is striking back at
Governor Gavin Newsom in California who
suggested kidnapping charges for Rhonda
santis for relocating these illegal
immigrants and I don't know if you've
seen these videos but this looks like
the best well not this but you've seen
the pictures of them on the plane and on
that luxury bus maybe the best
kidnapping case ever
they look like they're having a great
time they're all in their 20s and 30s if
you look at them they're all healthy
nobody is wearing you know bags and
looks like they're fleeing anyone look
at these guys yeah they're having a
better time than I had yesterday this is
complete Insanity these are not Asylum
Seekers I don't know what they are what
brought them to our border uh but look
if Governor uh if Governor Newsom Gavin
Newsom is upset with anyone he should be
upset with Joe Biden for letting these
people in now ironically he shouldn't be
upset because he wants California to be
a sanctuary state in Los Angeles and San
Francisco et cetera to be Sanctuary
cities just like New York so she he
should be very excited that they're
getting more people to enrich them
culturally and enhance the diversity
instead he's angry at DeSantis I think
he thinks that DeSantis is President
probably he will be we shall see uh but
but it's just pandering ridiculous
dribble by Newsome Newsome if you're so
excited about having Sanctuary States
and Sanctuary cities
congratulations you got 36 more people
he's definitely going to run for
president this is all this is all just
pretense for his presidential run he
can't jump in yet you also appointed
that Robert Kennedy Jr was down the
Border last night that's another story
that's not going to be covered on CNN as
you pointed out Dave maybe you should be
the CEO of CNN the new CEO there
I got a real job man I don't have time
for that but uh
look there's Robert Kennedy this is this
morning it's 2 A.M uh today he's there
he's talking about how these migrants
that are pouring in and there's hundreds
of them pouring in behind him they're
not just from Mexico not that that would
make it any better he's talking about
how they're from Afghanistan uh they're
from all sorts of countries all over the
place and look at the people behind him
do they look like they're fleeing
anything and even if they were fleeing
something we still have a right to
defend a border right the beauty of RFK
doing this is he's still a Democrat I'm
not sure why I'm going to have him on
the show soon and we'll discuss it but
the fact that now he will be considered
a racist outlier of his own party
because he's saying we should have a
border I don't know if you happen to
hear his Twitter spaces with Elon yeah
he talked about it I said we should shut
down the Border that's right in that
video right there and that Twitter
spaces is why they don't want him on the
debate stage and they won't cover them
on a lot of the mainstream media Dave
great to see you we got to run to a
commercial break we appreciate it
real job don't forget
I don't I'll never forget it okay great
to see you
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell